Charlie you've written a really
remarkable book it's recaptured a piece
of American history that I think most
Americans have totally forgotten and I
have to confess it I forgot a fair
amount of it you know this whole story
of how Wendell Willkie emerged could you
tell us a little about Wilkie himself
first and what kind of a man he was and
how he how he did emerge no well he came
from a small town in Indiana
Elwood population 10,000 he grew up
there the son of two lawyers his mother
was the first one admitted to the
Indiana bar oh that's so he came from a
rural background yet it was educated
argumentative back were you know with
two lawyers in the house at imagine so
the dinner table each night was a debate
society with his with his brothers
sisters and his mother and father so
while he had these rural roots he also
had this of training in discourse no
yeah then he went he went in the army
emerged a captain did he see action no
no he got to France yeah didn't see
action he then went to Akron Ohio and
practice ball there was a Democrat yeah
went to the first that went as a
delegate to the Democratic convention in
1924 oh the famous deadlocked where
where he fought for a plank against this
ku klux kyon you may remember that one
of the great shames of the Democratic
Party was because to keep the solid
South in line they were they were very
tender toward the Klan oh and they loved
the ghost hanging over Wilkie what was
fighting against the Klan in fact it was
one of the marks and as he grew up in
Indiana and again when he was in Ohio
that the the of the good guys against
the bad guys were fighting the Klan look
yeah that's a forgotten yes so cerritos
you know that people didn't don't know
that the Klan existed in the north and
was powerful in many northern state
yes so and then his other plank he
fought for was the League of relations
for the League of Nations
uh-huh and the Democrats had already
begun to desert the league in droves
yeah well they cut the country was
headed toward isolationism forward
strong isolationism Lee they revulsion
at this slaughter of World War one was
was tremendous yeah well just as
imperialist right whoever you know began
so isolationism was understandably very
strong and but Wilkie was an
internationalist even back then so his
his he was consistent in that all the
way through right and he rose to power
he he became he was one of the his
clients was a public utility in Akron
and I think it's the one that's now that
became Ohio Edison and he gained the
attention of a big New York Utility
Commonwealth the owner of Commonwealth
and Southern and that fella brought BC
Cobb brought him to New York
uh-huh where he quickly became president
of Commonwealth and southern he he was
extremely able man he was gifted and
dynamic and he began to move in New York
circles the financial and then and then
he met a woman named I read of endurance
and she was the book editor of the New
York Herald Tribune mm-hmm
well she became his mistress he one of
his characteristics was an eye for the
ladies yes and she became his mistress
and she introduced him to the New York
literary and journalistic world and he
added a gloss of sophistication to the
old barefoot boy of Indiana yeah in fact
Harold Ickes when he read Wilkie read
for president sarcastically referred to
him as the barefoot boy from Wall Street
not so far off glorious life so he that
he then having gone both in the ends of
those that literary and journalistic
world as well as the world of business
yes and having gained some prominence as
a anti New Deal critic particularly of
the regulatory agencies he was one of
those Republicans who was in many ways
sympathetic to the goals of the New Deal
but felt that HIPAA the New Deal would
be a lot better off if it wasn't run by
all those crazy professors down in
Washington to many Harvard guys never
remember that wonderful dig darling
cartoons the New York Herald Tribune all
a bunch of nutty professors down there
watched it take regarding machinery and
gumming up the machinery it was like The
Three Stooges and I guess an academic so
anyway so Wilkie and and and then the
moderate Republican South thought of
themselves as as running the New Deal
more efficiently mmm-hmm so he was in
that Trevin that tradition he then began
I think before it's commonly known I
think he began to think of running for
president I get that it was his idea I
first mentioned in the book I wasn't
personally clear the first mention of it
was well there was a difference between
one reason it's not clear is that I have
my own suspicions I said I didn't have
enough actual evidence right but the
first evidence in 1937 he was having a
sandwich with a fellow named Carlton
McVeigh at a place called the exchange
buffet on Wall Street and McVeigh said
why don't you run for president mm-hmm
McVeigh that same year wrote a little
monograph he was a aide to John diem
Hamilton the head of the Republican
National Committee yes he was also
extremely well Curt if his roommate at
Harvard had been Corliss Lamont the son
the son of Thomas Lamont the head of the
house of Morgan City where he was an
extremely connected
yes but also with some experience in
practical politics yes so my guess is
that the the game began then mm-hmm and
soon that then of an article auditory of
will keep appeared in Fortune in 1937
yeah the editor of fortune at that time
was Russell downpour who later by some
coincidence became Wilkie's closest aide
Davenport at one point devote a whole
issue I was later I love that only Time
magazine had the Golf time make it
really a truly so this was important so
I think it was under way then but it was
totally unacceptable
so that he would emerge as as a
candidate in the event of a deadlock at
the convention mm-hmm and it may even
have been that put in the original plan
was hard hatched it was that he would
run as a Democrat because he did not
leave the Republican Party it's not
there's no clear evidence he left the
Republican Party until January of 1940
the New York Sun Radek story said he has
registered as you have to read every
word he was toying with running against
FDR and the primary again this is a
suspicion but in any event as it became
clear clear that Roosevelt was going to
run for a third term and and Wilkie also
was very critical of that regulatory
aspect you deal
yeah.he by this time the New Deal had
become identified with a sort of
anti-business yes right right right
that's right so and Wilkie was a I had
become a prominent critic so it was
natural for him to veer toward the
Republican Party and for the Republicans
to find him attractive
mm-hm as a eloquent critic of the New
Deal yes
so they big the big things happened that
changed all this happened in
of 1940 Wilkie had in addition to being
at the critic of the New Deal had also
been a firm at and vigorous critic of
Adolf Hitler and a warning of the danger
of Hitler hmm so that when did I know
well that it started in the late 30s may
is making Anna other speeches around the
yeah so he and Roosevelt agreed pretty
much on foreign policy yes yes so as in
April the 9th 1940 Hitler invaded Norway
and Denmark right just by chance that
evening Wilkie bathing appearance on the
radio show information please which of
the nation of the nation's educated
elite that show was their school I
really love they loved us and so he he
was marvelous he was charming he talked
about Nicholas Nickleby he talked about
Matthew Arnold with wind and air you
dition and but he also talked about the
presidential politics so empty on the
only audience was just completely snowed
faster so the fix wasn't in there right
now so this was a coincidence that makes
it even more impressive I think it
really was a very woman he was he was a
very smart man yeah remember his father
had the largest library in Elwood and
then he is mistress was I read about
Doris so so any so here were these two
amazing events happening on the same day
mm-hmm that week the fortune was out
with this with this issue that was
Russell Davenport Wilkie's Fred that
devoted almost entirely to whether
working yes and he had an army the
people about a young lawyer named Orrin
root decided he would send that out to
his friends uh-huh
and people this was this big this was a
movement that began as an elite moment
at the movement if you ever heard of
yeah were sent to a mailing list of the
Yale and Princeton alumni 9 10 25 and 26
because rich roommate in his law firm
happened to be from Yale root was from
Princeton and they had the mailing list
of those two classes but then this
amazing thing happened the people were
so struck by that got it they sent in
immediately for more copies of the
petition of the Wilkie petition that
though people who got that sent out for
more copies and as this incredible
growth happened in by the 1st of May
they had 200,000 people and this was
because the country was waking up to the
Hadean jure post by Hitler becoming
alarmed by it
and here was Wilkie the only Republican
taking a firm stand against it so that
made Andrew - there's no slouch in
politics was it he was got his
grandfather had been Elia Road that's
right Oh was a sinner also left laubrain
right so here was this amazing volunteer
movement or you know and and the history
marching on Wilkie side but then Henry
Luce who was then controlled the most
influential publication in American Life
magazine George Gallup compared the
power of Life magazine to he said a
two-page spread in life was worth the
equal of a front-page story on every
newspaper in the United States and that
was true then it was a it was the
amazing I think it was the equivalent to
all the television yes so loose through
his power including Time magazine which
was a very influential middle-class
political thank you very fortunate in
fluent on Wall Street all that went
totally behind Wilkie because Luce to
was vigorously anti-hitler and so and
loose also admired a liberal businessman
I can't just we call them responsible
business right
and he saw himself yeah I'm right right
exactly exactly Alan Brinkley told me
that he felt loose was a hero worship
her in a way and we'll keep became a
hero to it what it what a Claire think
of Claire liked him too ah and Claire
kind of turned against him in the end
but that'll work about three or four
years later oh right but at this time
she was she was a hundred percent for it
rooting for him in the gallery at at
Philadelphia so here you and then and
then Wilkie had the New York Herald
Tribune his mistress Irina Van Doren was
close friends with the owners of The
Herald Tribune right so he had the
Herald Tribune and he she introduced him
to Dorothy Thompson the influential
Tribune columnist to Menace who
supported him during the adventure and
walter Lippmann the other help big
Herald Tribune commas began to lean
heavily toward Wilkie and finally just
totally for him before the convention
yes so there was this tremendous media
push and then the Warren news got worse
and worse and worse
yeah if France wasn't and Belgium and
Holland were invaded Belgium and Holland
were quickly overrun then then came
Dunkirk
right and this will the I thought this
is the one the best things in the book
was you caught you you make the reader
realize that these disasters in Europe
were happy just as the Republican
convention was taking place it's just
it's just like you know like a
searchlight had been put on this and and
to cut the ground out from under the
isolationist on June 23rd France fell
well one of the isolationist main point
said did well not to worry about this
guy Hitler the French army is the best
in the world
oh yeah we don't have to worried that
they got that Maginot Line man they got
that Maginot Line no Hitler can't get
through that well here the the mighty
French army was defeated
you know you know the day before the
convention opens so this was had
tremendous influence yeah this is what I
think people have forgotten you know
that's why the book is so good and so a
convention I think the majority of the
delegates were naturally conservative
isolationist I think the candidate that
they would the most loved to vote for
was Robert Taft and he ended up running
closest to Wilkie yeah and and the
convention has to have been one of the
most exciting in the history of the
country because it started out with
Wilkie had a hundred and five of the 501
votes he needed yeah first ballot yeah
Thomas Dewey the district attorney from
New York had 360 he was the youngest
yeah he had been the leader in all the
polls right up until her convention and
but people had begun to be worried about
his youth mm-hm and his lack of
international experience yes man some
people have begun to get the frigid
rigidity that you know one of his
closest aides reasonable Cormac Sims
said he was cold cold as an iceberg in
February
thing about that man I've been able to
figure that true yeah so anyway so doing
even though he was ahead he was falling
and he made a tremendous mistake on the
first ballot he he he overestimated his
strength yeah that immediately people
saw that he lost votes on the second
ballot mm-hm and smart politicians would
hellhound back votes on the first ballot
so they could prove them in yes in the
book you have somebody and they just
yeah right we know what we're doing and
so anyway so Taft emerged as the as the
leading conservative can yeah let's
let's mentioned that this is the son of
a president the son of son of William
Howard not exactly a nobody no-nobody
yes and he had but he had just become a
senator two years before yeah that's it
he was a young man I wasn't aware
and he but he had already he soaked
communicated to the people that mr.
Republican identity that he immediately
won the hearts of the conservative
isolationist in the country but he also
you have a wonderful scene in the book
where he turned off the liberal Republic
this when when he went to that dinner
party tell us about that yeah this was a
barbless story though I owe this to
James D Patterson iboga fer of Pam he
Taft and his wife were invited to a
dinner party at the home of Helen and
Ogden Reed they were the owners I read
of and Oren's friends the owners of The
Herald Tribune the dinner party of the
taff's knew was going to be composed of
all liberal Republican isolation
internationalist so this was walking
into the dead and Martha his wife were
on their good behavior because they
thought they were going to win at the
convention and in that case they had to
win these guys over for the general
election so the evening was going very
politely and warmly and then Wilkie who
was another guest at the party Wilkie
said well I wouldn't vote for the
Republican candidate that if he was an
isolationist Wow and at that moment Taft
exploded and this wild argument broke
out okay and Martha Martha Martha said I
thought I was going to have to throw
pepper everybody was screaming at each
other it's a great see that really those
so the convention then we and then the
Wilkie started a really gain Lola Wilkie
started to gain and a big factor in
wookies game was this is another story a
month before the convention the chairman
of the Arrangements committee which
controls the tickets to the convention
was a man named Ralph William
and at the meeting of the committee
committee in Philadelphia he had a heart
attack and died because he control who
got in he controlled who got it he
panted out the tickets and so well the
vice chairman of the committee was a
Wilkie man so it got Dave I thought same
price I own fries yes Sam fryer got
control of the tickets and that then
this tremendous volunteer movement that
this fella Orrin root had organized well
those volunteers poured into
Philadelphia right and Sam fries I said
listen baby we got tickets for chanting
we want Wilkie we want Wilkie and that
chant somebody I was on a radio show a
couple months ago and somebody played
that records of that oh I'm not hearing
that that wasn't fest and it was chilly
I mean the power of it so you can
imagine the delegate had to be impressed
yeah even though we sympathized with TAS
so in addition the Wilkie volunteers
from all over the country we're sending
these letters and telegrams
so the mailboxes of the guys back at the
hotel
were stuffed with these letters and
telegrams but back home saying both for
Wilkie long the day of the conveyance of
that the balloting the Thursday of that
when they were voting 40,000 telegrams
arrived on the floor of the convention
Wilkie that's not an accident those
things just those are got a work on but
still very effective at that afternoon
that Philadelphia evening bulletin had
an article on the front page by Joseph
Alsop
that revealed that the coming Gallup
poll was going to say Wilkie had moved
ahead
so all these things came together though
we want Wilkie chance that telegrams the
letters that then the story saying that
those people weren't just talking up
there in the gallery they represented
the people now that's this is where the
popular will was going yeah
so that the balloting went it taft moved
up and so off after the after the fifth
ballot
it was Wilkie 429 Taft 377 still very
close and the sixth ballot it went back
and back and forth back and forth and
there's a good story and the guy from
Michigan
yeah tell us that what shows that Wilkie
as a practical politician right down
through I think down through Louisiana
all the way through Louisiana Wilkie led
by only one vote and then John diem on
Hamilton who it's the sky Charlton that
they had swung over to Wilkie side he
went to the chairman of the Michigan
delegation a guy named Frank McKay and
he said you know Frankie you owe me a
favor
and this is the time for you to come
through and Frank said well I want to
make their care one thing I want to be
sure that you don't let those Wilkie
volunteers control the judgeships in
Michigan and so as an old Jersey City
politician I know what that means a
judge to decide whether people go to
jail or not the the Wilkey forces Sam
Pryor called Wilkie at the hotel and
said here's the deal do you want to make
it and Wilkie said yes let's do it there
so Wilkie who had been sublimely it
really he was very pure on the whole he
had not made any deals there right up
until this time but at the crucial
moment he made a deal Jesuit philosopher
would not have found anything wrong with
that he would have gotten that was the
feeling it
so then then that that really was the
decisive moment Taft
you know the tap people were working
desperately and you can just imagine in
in that that convention hall it was ah
it must have been a hundred degrees
he knows he ever seen the summer it's
out summer in Philadelphia all these
bodies in this hall and then they had
these bright lights for the newsreel
cameras and there's some of the people
wore sunglasses these lights were so
really so they here was the sweat
pouring off their faces there and and
this wasn't just an ordinary political
decision because these isolationist many
of them felt very strongly you know I
thought I did feel I could imagine
myself at that time being the revulsion
of world war one could have made me an
isolationist at that time he said just
that you've just that horrible slaughter
and so those people felt very strongly
on the other hand that will keep people
felt that this guy Hitler was going to
rule the world if we didn't take a stand
and that it was a moral duty of a horse
to come immediately to the aid of
Britain and France Britain shutting out
Britain alone that convention really so
it was so these people you can imagine
the effort each side was putting into
that last ballasting but now came
Pennsylvania and this was going to be
the world tafs last hope and the big
does a big job and he clearly was
leaning strongly toward Taft and so Taft
was counting on getting those busts but
it turned out the delegates themselves
were leaning more and more toward Wilkie
and the ranking member I can file so
that there it's there situations where a
boss can't if the troops it decides
straight oh I there they're gone astray
and and finally they rebelled and they
had been voting for a favorite son
governor Arthur James as a holding
action
but finally on that six pellets they
broke and they said they were going to
go for Taft
and there was no I mean Fort will kill
yeah and and so that meant there was no
hope for TAS yes so so the this man then
this Dark Horse as they called them just
walked away with this incredible prize
and I read out the week with a hundred
and five of the five hundred and one
votes he needed and I was interesting
that the New York Times wrote an
editorial saying that the Republicans
have put forward their strongest
candidate right that next one they had
they put that if you could amend it
would not repeat they were not in
federal uh they were not Democrats know
at 1:30 that morning that was the
convention that balloting was never to
what their so the time's editors put
that editorial to it and I think that
the final edition went to press at 3:30
in those days yes yes they were up you
can see them burning the midnight oil up
in that office of the tower The Times
getting that editorial ready isn't that
well Charlie we're going to take a break
for a few minutes and now we're going to
come back to the another convention of
the Democratic convention which is an
equally interesting story in the Balkan
good afterwards with Charles Peters and
Thomas Fleming we'll continue in a
moment
tonight on c-- span's QA pennsylvania
senator Arlen Specter on his battle with
cancer and the upcoming hearings on John
Roberts Supreme Court nomination my
first line of questions will be on the
central issue in this whole matter or
that is a woman's right to choose
senator Arlen Specter tonight at 8:00
Eastern and Pacific on c-span Q&A you
can also listen to Q&A on c-span radio
it's available on Sirius satellite radio
channel 113 XM satellite radio channel
132 and also available as a c-span
podcast next weekend on afterwords
journalist and author Barbara Ehrenreich
discusses her new book on the working
conditions of American white-collar
workers it's titled bait-and-switch the
futile pursuit of the American dream
she's interviewed by Stephen Moore
senior economics writer for The Wall
Street Journal watch afterwards at its
new time Saturday evenings at 8:00
Eastern and again Sundays at 6:00 and
9:00 p.m. Eastern on book TV on c-span
2
[Music]
afterwards with Charles Peters and
Thomas Fleming continues Charlie the
title of your book is five days in
Philadelphia which is - you just told us
what lively days they were but there's
another convention that took place in
Chicago that is also in the book and I
think that has some very interesting
things happening - oh and this this
convention in it illustrates the the
problem FDR was up against that summer
in trying to get away with aiding
Britain instituting a military draft in
this country to prepare us for World War
two he in June just - that the week that
the day the convention started June 24
yes his top national security advisors
including general Marshall Admiral Stark
Sumner Welles had come to his office and
said you can't give anything more to
Britain the cover we've got to keep what
we have and so Roosevelt wanted to date
England but he the importance of Wilkie
began to be that became very clear then
because he needed a Republican
opposition who wouldn't criticize him
and who wouldn't use leaks that were
bound to come from these national
security guys yes that this Roosevelt is
endangering the country with this policy
there's another issue although that's
the third term and and do you have an
absolutely wonderful scene in the book
of Roosevelt and Jim falling between
Roosevelt and Jim's falling which meant
it it's if I might say so I meant a
great deal to me because I knew falling
pretty well before I died another factor
that made a weakened Roosevelt at that
time was there was strong opposition in
the country to a third term I I would
say that at least a third of the
Democratic Party was worried if not
outright opposed
by about a third term and of course all
the Republicans grew and falling was the
guy who and Jim Farley an elected
relative to previous time the chairman
of the Democratic National Committee the
key political adviser to Roosevelt he
had wanted to run for president in 1940
he was against the third term but he
also had his personal ambition
yeah and Roosevelt was the body's pure
rose Roosevelt was in the way
and so there was this fascinating
meeting between Roosevelt and Farley at
Hyde Park in July early July of 1940 in
which Roosevelt was obviously trying to
get Farley to come over and support him
Farley was trying to get Roosevelt to
support him
and it's it's a marvelous powerful men
toe-to-toe nose-to-nose and they were
they were not going to movie at one
another
and Roosevelt kept tried though during
the convention he made a couple of calls
to Farley which he was again tried to
maneuver Farley around he wasn't asked
that and Roosevelt could usually caught
almost anybody but Farley he was so
anyway but Roosevelt was in a somewhat
weakened position or a dangerous
position because that this advice from
his military advisors not to give any
more aid to Britain by his running for a
third term which was upsetting a lot of
people including some in his own party
and so that convention my father took us
to that convention yes you had and so I
was just thirteen years old but I
imagined myself as as a full of
political oh wise man yeah and I was
would circulate around the hotel lobbies
listening to the delegates I used you
know the papers and they they had
multiple editions of newspapers as you
didn't have the radio bulletins so you
had each paper put out about seven
editions yes and so my fingers would get
black and with newspaper
acres each of these they
I was holding up the paper as I sat in
the chair trying to overhear what the
delegates were saying yeah well what the
delegates were saying was mostly a very
much greatly disturbed about Harry
Hopkins who was Roosevelt's agent
running the convention yes they and they
were upset that Roosevelt was kind of
disrespecting Jim Farley they felt and
these are them regularly yeah it was it
was you know there are coming from
Jersey City my father yeah I was
metaphorically at that convention too
you know and I understand exactly what
it was there was a lot of anger yeah so
then in a beautiful moment mrs.
Roosevelt who had made had a very good
relationship with Jim Farley over the
years she asked barley if she should
come to the convention and Farley said
yes without your husband's in trouble
and I'm part of it but he barley was a
wonderful you know I love the kind of
man who will get who was a good advisor
I always took pride in myself as being a
good advice yes and would you give good
advice against your own interest that is
the toughest challenge in the world well
and Farley did that Farley told her to
come and the personal relationship
obviously learn more then well can I say
that perhaps had something to do with
his Irish blood in any event there's a
great flame when the when the convention
was probably at its most rebellious
moment mrs. Roosevelt came to the
platform Farley escorted her the people
saw that it will solve the two of them
together then she paid this touching
tribute to Farley and that was just the
grace note that brought everything
together
the Ken Utley convention listen to that
had been yelling and booing and
everything it was just on the out of
control and the suddenly it was totally
quiet I was there I could it was just so
hard to believe if you'd been there an
hour before you thought Roosevelt was
going to be voted out
yes but chic she calmed them she quieted
them and she brought them back with that
wonderful phrase Doris Kearns Goodwin
used as a title of her book no this is
no ordinary time yeah and this is no
ordinary time and knowing this
convention that we have to mention
number one being the voice from the
sewer
oh this was and also Edie Kelly packing
the galleries with loss of Chicago that
they they had certainly learned a lesson
from the Wilkie people and and so they
the convention that the delegates were
not as sufficiently enthusiastic when
Roosevelt's name was mentioned fact
mayor Kelly was making a welcoming
speech and there was just the most tepid
applause when Roosevelt's name was
mentioned so if they decide to do
something about that so for something
there's some story of their Afghan about
the Johnny Joey and the boys for the
24th Ward they all arrived and somehow
there were slips of paper that were used
that they put the police which were also
under mayor Kelly's control that the
police chose to view as the equivalent
of a tick and there they were all the
public address system over the
publication he was later revealed to be
the superintendent of sewage and that's
why the hall so the Roosevelt did win
the the vote by a large margin 900 just
200 or something like that because the
delegates all felt that they their best
chance of winning was with Roosevelt
even even though a lot of those who
didn't burn enthusiastic about a third
term went along yeah it's still the
convention even with the healing spirit
of mrs. Roosevelt the convention ended
on a glum note yes
the liberal columnist Raymond clapper
who was ordinarily a sucker for
Roosevelt he thrust a bitterly critical
yeah all about Roosevelt that next
Monday right and that was I remember the
feeling my feeling is a loyal Democrat
at that time was glum riding home
yeah and so Roosevelt was in a weakened
position hmm so that this is why Wilkie
was so important mhmmm Wilkie Wilkie
then supported Roosevelt on this yeah
after this is the most amazing thing to
me because this was the first peacetime
draft in our history mm-hmm and it was
coming up before Congress it was finally
voted on on September the 16th I believe
of 1940 yeah less than two months before
a general election that took in America
and American politics
you just don't bring up something like
this so for both Roosevelt and Wilkie
mm-hmm it took tremendous courage
tremendous statesmanship rising above
partisanship for the good of the poor
what they felt was the good yes yes so
that well I think find that breathtaking
in the history of American politics I
agree with you I think it is a
remarkable absolutely north and then
Roosevelt was also England desperately
needed all kinds of aid but most of all
they needed destroyers to help repel a
Nazi invasion across the across the
channel yes and to fight the submarines
we were their main enemy so Roosevelt
was trying to maneuver this deal to give
them the Destroyers of the theory said
there were several laws and suspected
that Roosevelt was up to something so
issued he'd gotten an amendment passed
to a naval appropriations bill that
seemed I absolutely forbid Massachusetts
Irish Irish
and the German German Americans and
Irish Americans really means main
strength of the isolationist and of
course the Irish Americans you had to
love because they were torn most of them
have been very Pro Roosevelt OS and so
they were they were pro Roosevelt one
way but they hated the Brits that was a
very much important phenomenon i really
wasn't true in Jersey City that's
interest now feeling was was a localized
that's it but anyway but you have a very
interesting point in the book about
maybe this is the beginning of the
Imperial present yeah and I think I
think it could be yeah
so what Roosevelt did he cooked up this
by the way comes from his World War one
experience which I think many people
underestimate an understanding brosef I
quietly Roosevelt Roosevelt learned the
bureaucracy in world where he learned
Washington he learned an immense amount
about how government works
that's right between the policymaker and
the bureaucratic right and that's where
you can learn a lot and yeah and most of
these guys have been here for 45 years
and most of these guys are come to
watched it they don't know diddly about
how the place works so you know it takes
them a year to find out where the men's
room is and and and and then you know it
just goes it's such a long learning
period Roosevelt view that stuff anyway
Roosevelt one of the things he'd figured
out was that the use of the lease and so
he decided he could week at least these
Brett bases to Britain there was no
there was no law that specifically used
that word lead yeah in return for but we
had to get something in return
yeah yeah so we had to get this these
bases the British bases they they gave
us the leases on their bases right and
in a few cases about Churchill's
insistence they out they gave us the
outright
yes title to the bases
so eat and the beauty of this was that
even the Chicago Tribune which was the
buzzin I saw that was at a point most
isolations paper in the country but I'm
saying if Roosevelt was good he'd get us
those basis but that the British have
that we would that they we need to
protect the Western Hemisphere because
he their idea was never go to Europe to
war but if you had to protect the West
yes yes well so the Chicago Tribune what
Roosevelt pulled this deal they could
criticize it because he was getting all
those bases that they had say so I woke
he supported those yeah yeah he's very
caught well he never truly involved they
they had they had to they withdrew
tremendous difficulty in getting him to
to agree to support it they had because
Arthur Kroc who was a big influential
Republican Congress of the New York
Times and variant Lee Rosen hated and
and rock hated Roosevelt and crock was
out the screw Roosevelt any way he could
yeah so when I and Herbert Hoover who
felt similarly about the president they
conspired to keep Wilkie from endorsing
the destroyer to you but finally wrote
Wilkie sent the signal to Roosevelt that
he would not criticize or he would not
repudiate the D or call for the deal
right which was all that was good and
that's what he stuck by he'd he he then
after the deal was made
he criticized it as being the beginning
of the imperial presidency should use
that turn it no he says he said well
President Roosevelt should have gone to
Congress right get their approval
well the Joker there is if Roosevelt had
called the Congress the same week he was
weeks he was asking for a draft yeah and
with another controversial measure it
would have caused hell would broke could
Lucy what he might not have gotten
either I think so so so that was a
judgment yes and and I think Roosevelt
was absolutely right but but history
will also show that Roosevelt went a
long way beyond what had previously been
acknowledged as the power
the presidency today yes you know but I
think when you look back in history
though they said that about times
whenever some of the Louisiana Purchase
and so it's a judgment call that a
president has to make I love Roosevelt
yeah what an operator he was immediately
he saw the Louisiana Purchase and in his
railroad car he was head bent my
hometown Charleston West Virginia they
were leaving Charleston going up the New
River Gorge and he had the press
conference in his railroad car
announcing the the deal yet had he
several times that that conference
referred to the Louisiana Purchase
because he wanted to set the tone of the
cover and I go the next day a lot of the
newspapers talked about just like the
Louisiana Purchase Draft he never
referred to it as a draft he said it's a
mustard yeah you know rich with
reminiscence of the colonialists
gathering on the right to march off
yeah the British are very important
though I think over all but I came
across something I did a little homework
I got out one of my files on the FDR
tapes you know they take and you brought
someone you quote some of them in a book
you know and one thing I came of course
that surprised me was that Rose haven't
really gotten mad at Wilkie at one point
on the tapes you know he didn't like the
way Wilkie was saying I'm gonna put nine
million people back to work Oh Rosa
veldt was very sensitive on that point
yeah Roosevelt had it's funny history
it's hard to say look back and say
whether history was fair or unfair to
Roosevelt but in in this respect he had
reduced the unemployment from 25 million
to 10 million yes that was a hell of a
reductive that sub histories read as if
the Depression was just going on
constantly during the third and that
there was no difference there was a heck
of a difference yeah that's the greater
just just and just in the in the last
year in my home state West Virginia
which is not a leading indicator of
prosperity ordinarily the the wages had
grown up 25 percent in so that the week
we were a lot of progress had been made
but still would you do very nice job on
on the you quote about the from the
Roseville tapes of the scandal of Wilkie
and versus vice president wise we didn't
mention that henry wallace and president
this was another fact the henry wallace
not of choices vice president was
another factor causing enormous
disturbance at the convention because
wallace was not popular he was a very
earnest and very good secretary of
agriculture right but he had some
unusual qualities he was a mystic and he
had unfortunately written several
letters to about a hundred to a guy
named Rory was that his name yeah and
anyway yeah and it got noticed some of
these letters and they were threatening
to to publish them so Roosevelt there's
this type of Roosevelt in the White
House talking to Lord Melek one of his
assistants they say well if they do that
we ought to get we gotta get out the
word about this this lady friend of of
Wilkie says I read it Van Doren she's a
swell gal I understand but nonetheless
so I think there was a beautiful I just
a D between the two caps that they were
gonna touch this
and yeah there was no mention of the
yeah eventually those letters I think in
1944 maybe 48 they did get published the
other one the other one wasn't that
Roosevelt was lucky to escape was that
you know just they are they had gone
down to Alabama the present the
presidential party to attend the funeral
of all speaker back in something well
home the Trent home the train going down
there Sumner Welles the Undersecretary
of State had propositioned a Pullman
Porter yes who happened to be black so
you can imagine what the stories would
have been that if that if that story had
gotten out but he was drunk when he was
he did it but in those days the press
was extremely kind about not getting
into the sex lives of pop so I think
they had protected will Keanu Rita Van
Doren at a press conference it I read of
at dorrance apartment oh my god no
reporter wrote a word about it there was
never a word that appeared about the
that relationship yeah as we're now in
the campaign yes okay and the anger in
the campaign while both men had been I
think risen to great heights on the
draft yeah they didn't stay on the
heights during the campaign Wilkie began
to kind of recklessly attack Roosevelt
and and and got to indicating that he
thought Roosevelt would immediately lead
us into war yeah call them a third
yeah and which was a bright line and so
anyway that made that made that made
Roosevelt very angry so and then Mose
Abell kind of began to out promise
Wilkie about keeping us out of war yeah
and and then made that speech in Boston
that and I will not send your boys I'll
never send you more and more right yeah
so I got to admit that that has always
troubled me probably you know it was the
trouble Roosevelt's advisor said Sam
Rosalyn reminded him at the convention
there was going to be a platform plank
yeah saying that absolutely we won't sin
and Roosevelt had added at Roosevelt's
instructions except in case of it at
that point
that's so Bob Sherwood who was writing
the speech at that Boston speech sure
wouldn't say well mr. president you said
except an attack in the platform why
don't we say it here you know Nate we
don't need to it's obvious and so that
was you say there his argument for the
obvious rather weak it was very weak
yeah and so and so Sherwood says that
Robert Sherwood was the famous
playwright and everything page writer
for FDR antique Keith later wrote in a
book Roosevelt Hopkins that he thought
Roosevelt was most ashamed of that
campaign of anything it does yeah so but
but you could see if that's true and I
think it is that was he sensed it was an
absolute necessity in order to win the
election oh it was because Wilkie had
was coming up at the end he and will
Roosevelt ended up with what seemed like
an impressive margin of 27 million to 22
million yeah 22 million was fine for
votes that any Republican candidate ever
gotten before so very that Wilkie was
the high point in votes for a Republican
candidate till that time yes sir that
showed the amount of enthusiasm and
dedication he had arousing those
volunteers those people well yeah yeah
and then cumson now the the next stage I
think we want to get into if we have a
little time is how Wilkie then continued
after the election to support Roosevelt
as he struggled to prepare the country
for war and so forth I think that's in
some ways the most remarkable thing well
Lucas biographer most recent biographers
Steve Neil said that Wilkie went down to
Florida to stay at Sam priors retreat
down in Florida after the election
there's a picture in the book of him
down there there was this fish yes I saw
yeah and he Wilkie and Steve said that
Wilkie decided then and there that he
was going to make his main cause thus
helping Britain survive he thought that
was so important so that yeah Wilkie
then planned this trip to London he
informed Roosevelt that he was going to
go and Roosevelt decided to use Wilkie
to carry a message to Churchill Wilkie
carried that message to Churchill with
the long feller Longfellow poem yes
say hello no ship of state right and
Churchill made this wonderful reply that
so understood American politics yes it
was his reply to the American president
and the American people was give us the
tools and we will do the job that was
other words you send us the equipment
and we will do the job you won't have to
send your soldiers if you send us so
Roosevelt was trying to sell this
lend-lease bill yeah give to get in
effect to give Britain the the tool the
tools that came in and we'll keep as
help
and so here Churchill said exactly the
right thing to help Roosevelt sell the
deal yes yes and remember I think he did
a good job I will key to Churchill later
wrote that we we devoted every resource
to giving Wilkie of the impression that
would help us that's four times so the
result was that accorded the point that
things were looking tough for the
lend-lease bill Cordell Hull who was
Roosevelt's Secretary of State cabled
Wilkie in London and said come back we
need you to testify before the
Relations Committee Wilkie flew back his
he gave the testimony and the testimony
in the opinion of many many observers
was what got the bill passed house
number one eight said yeah well he was
the man who did it look could we sum up
Charlie with that you have a wonderful
statement by Wilkie of what he thought
his legacy was at the when he was
looking back on his life at after you
know for several years and not long
before he died it he said he said I
would rather than be just an average
president I would rather have had have
it said of me that at a crucial moment
in our history I served the cause of
freedom and he did he at that crucial
moment he I think he did the things that
had to be done to save the Western world
and I agree with you and I think that is
the essential message of this really
fine book and Charlie it's been such a
pleasure to talk about this to old
appalled literary Paul